I have a crypto podcast so I speak to
the expert and I listen I remember like
a year ago I interviewed Ralph pal just
before Luna crashed Bitcoin was coming
down and I was asking him like why is
Bitcoin coming down like what's going on
and you know he explained to me the
whole concept of like because of
inflation people don't have like Surplus
cash to start investing into crypto
anymore and because that's when
inflation really started to kick in
about a year ago so you know I'm
learning from them and then also before
I had my podcast I worked as a
journalist I would also just interview
people all day and yeah I just shut up
and listen and you actually learn
something